[Music]
welcome back this week scott atlas left
his position as white house coronavirus
advisor for years
dr atlas was a senior member of stanford
university's department of medicine
i know stanford well i taught there when
i first moved to america in 2012 and
i've always been grateful
for the opportunities it gave me but on
november the 20th the university's
faculty senate condemned
dr atlas they said his actions quote
contradict medical science they claim
he misrepresented knowledge and opinion
regarding the management of pandemics
showing disdain for established medical
knowledge and they alleged
that he violated stanford's core values
and high ethical standards
high ethical standards interesting
earlier in the year three current
members of stanford's medical faculty
epidemiologists john yanidis jay
batacharya and aaron bendavid published
a study
that completely upended what we thought
we knew about the virus
by testing antibodies in santa clara
county where stanford is based
the doctors established that coronavirus
was much more infectious
but much less deadly than we'd been told
this finding called into question the
entire strategy of our leaders
locking everyone down to try and stop
anyone being infected
if the virus was as infectious as the
stanford doctors showed
there's no point shutting down the
economy because that won't actually stop
the virus
and if it's much less deadly then for
most people it doesn't matter because
they'll have zero or mild symptoms
if they get infected the right policy
would be to protect the vulnerable
while letting everyone else get on with
their lives this was hugely significant
on this show we were the first to
criticize the lockdowns to say the cure
is worse than the disease
and we brought you the stanford doctor's
findings as soon as they're available dr
j bhattacharya joined us
on april the 12th what was the reaction
from stamford
this man lloyd miner is head of stanford
medicine
instead of supporting his colleagues
groundbreaking work he tried
to silence them using the pretext of a
manufactured whistleblower complaint he
ordered
an investigation for six months the
doctors
were threatened with retribution hounded
by stanford lawyers prevented from
speaking out
even subjected to smear campaigns in the
press
yet their pioneering findings have since
been confirmed
by multiple other studies this one
conducted in july and published in
september another more recently
from the cdc itself after six months the
doctors were completely exonerated
and able to speak freely again dr
bhattacharya became a founder
of the great barrington declaration
which argues against lockdowns and in
favor of what they call
focused protection for the vulnerable
it's been signed by over 12
000 medical and public health scientists
around the world
everything the stanford doctors said in
april was
true dr scott atlas shared their
analysis
and was a vocal advocate of the focused
protection approach
that's why the president hired him so
why did
stanford try to silence its own doctors
why did it smear dr atlas
because of this person dr sarah cody
santa clara county health officer she
ordered the nation's first
lockdown lockdown fanatics see her as a
hero
here's the queen of corona
misinformation msnbc's rachel maddow
dr cody and the other health officers in
the san francisco bay area acted faster
and more decisively
than anyone else in the country i didn't
know that
stay-at-home orders were within the
public health
toolkit how prepared were you how did
you all know to think about these things
as options good question
and here's the answer the lockdown plan
sarah cody ordered which then infected
so to speak the whole country
wasn't formulated in response to the
coronavirus it was an off-the-shelf plan
that she and some former colleagues had
prepared
after 9 11 as a response to a potential
bioterrorism attack
or a theoretical pandemic not on the
data or the science
of this pandemic still sarah cody
shot down santa clara county then the
bay area followed then the whole of
california
and then across the country we're
constantly told we have the best public
health system in the world
this week data was published showing
that the virus was circulating in
mid-december
2019. in late january this year
fauci was still telling us it was
nothing to worry about
the virus was here three months before
sarah cody's locked down
it was never going to contain it even at
the time the stanford antibody study
literally conducted
in sarah cody's county proved that
lockdowns were never going to contain it
yet preposterously given the data
sarah cody was still talking in june
this year
about quote full containment
what's all this got to do with stanford
and dr atlas
guess who sarah cody's husband is a
professor of medicine
at stanford and so they closed ranks to
protect their
own led by stanford medicine's boss
lloyd miner how dare anyone question the
lock down it was ordered
by the wife of our colleague this
is how the group thinks started the
stanford study
was the first scientific challenge to
the lockdown policy
so naturally it had to be destroyed the
dissenting doctors had to be attacked
smeared and silenced universities
science the whole point is to be open to
gather evidence to debate
stanford did the exact opposite they
attempted a cover-up it is grotesque
and a total disgrace meanwhile
the rest of us had to live with the
consequences the lockdown group think
spread from stanford to the medical
establishment to the media to the
bureaucrats and the democrats with
utterly cynical bad
faith and realizing the weakness of
their own position they accused
anyone against lockdown of wanting
people to die
but of course people died despite the
lockdown and thousands more died
because of the lockdown we brought you
the toll week after week
the establishment's cruel destructive
lockdowns failed
yet here we are again about to repeat
them
none of it's based on science or data
big
business open but small business clothes
25 this 50
that it is all capricious pseudo
scientific
nonsense look at biden with this
pathetic statement about masking in his
first hundred days it is pure bs
plucked out of thin air by some pr idiot
everything biden says about the virus is
for politics
not public health he has zero
credibility
lockdown leaders know their rules make
no sense
or they wouldn't break them all the time
every day
there's a new democrat lockdown
hypocrite
what moral authority do they have to
impose lockdowns on anyone
anywhere they're exploiting this virus
to micromanage our lives and we've had
enough of it
this lockdown group think is as wrong as
the establishment group thing
that gave us endless war in the middle
east the 50-year suck-up to china
but this is worse than both because the
costs are higher
lockdowns are the biggest public policy
mistake in history
and we have to fight them be responsible
protect the vulnerable live your life
help us fight back by following us at
steve hilton x and
next rev fnc and share this when we post
it